descubramos cómo calcular las raíces de
una función de tercer grado
tenemos la expresión fx igual a equis
cúbica menos x el primer paso es
encontrar las raíces de nuestra ecuación
así que factor hicimos como ambos
términos tienen una equis vamos a usar
el método de factor común y así tenemos
x por x al cuadrado menos 1 si
analizamos el término dentro del
paréntesis x al cuadrado menos 1 vemos
que tiene la forma de una diferencia de
cuadrados por lo que se puede volver a
factorizar
como seguro recuerdas la diferencia de
cuadrados es el resultado de un binomio
conjugado
vamos a usar esta regla para hacer más
pequeña nuestra expresión
a cuadrada menos b cuadrada es igual a b
x
b al factorizar esta diferencia de
cuadrados tendremos el binomio conjugado
x + 1 x x menos uno con ambos pasos
obtenemos los factores más pequeños de
nuestra función x por x + 1 por x 1
finalmente encontramos las raíces de
nuestra función para esto vamos a
igualar la a 0 entonces sería x x x + 1
x x 1 igual a 0 para que estos factores
multiplicados nos den 0 tenemos tres
posibilidades que x sea 0 que x 10 x 10
estas tres posibilidades son las
soluciones a nuestra función de tercer
grado
en la primera posibilidad no tenemos
nada que calcular porque x debe ser
igual a cero
para la segunda posibilidad tenemos la
ecuación x1 igual a cero
si despejamos x de esta ecuación
obtenemos x igual a menos 1 y en la
tercera posibilidad si despejamos x nos
queda x igual a 1
de esta manera tenemos las soluciones x
igual a menos 1 x 0 x igual a 1
si gráfica mos estos valores podemos
observar que nuestra función original
toca en estos puntos del eje x es decir
que vale cero trazamos nuestra primera
raíz que es cero
después menos 1 y por último 1 si en la
función sustituyéramos en x algunos
valores más como menos tres menos 2 2 y
3 encontraremos otras coordenadas por
donde pasa la gráfica como por ejemplo
menos tres menos 21 menos 2,8 2,8 y 3,21
y veremos que quedaría de esta forma así
tenemos la gráfica de la función
polinomio de tercer grado
es muy fácil resolver este tipo de
funciones solo tienes que conocer los
distintos métodos para factorizar te
invito a seguir practicando con el
siguiente ejercicio